when uh was spot born
around
2000 and uh 12 or so
so again almost 10 years into sort of a
run with DARPA where we built a bunch of
different quadrupeds we had a sort of a
different thread where we started
building humanoids
um we we saw that probably an end was
coming where the government was going to
kind of back off from a lot of Robotics
investment
and uh
in order to maintain progress we just
deduced that well we probably need to
sell ourselves to somebody who wants to
continue to invest in this this area and
that was Google
and so
um at Google we would meet regularly
with Larry Page
and Larry just started asking us you
know what's your product going to be and
you know the logical thing the thing
that we had the most history with that
we wanted to continue developing was our
quadruped
but we knew it needed to be smaller we
knew it couldn't have a gas engine we
thought it probably couldn't be
hydraulically actuated
so that began the process of exploring
if we could migrate to a smaller
electrically actuated
um robot and that was really the Genesis
of spot
so not a gas engine and the actuators
are electric yes so can you maybe
comment on what it's like
um my Google working with Larry Page
having those meetings and thinking of
what will a robot look like
that could be
built that scale what like starting to
think about a product
Larry always liked the the toothbrush
test he wanted products that you used
every day
um
what they really wanted was
you know a consumer level product
something that would work in your house
we didn't think that was the right next
thing to do because to be a consumer
level product cost is going to be very
important
probably needed to cost a few thousand
dollars and we were we were building
these machines that cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars maybe a million
dollars to build of course we were only
building a two but
but we didn't see how to get all the way
to this consumer level product in a
short amount in a short amount of time
and he suggested that we we make the
robots really inexpensive
and part of our philosophy has always
been
build the best hardware you can
make make the machine operate well so
that you're trying to solve
you know discover that the hard problem
that you don't know about don't don't
make it harder by by building a crappy
machine basically you build the best
machine you can there's plenty of hard
problems to solve that are going to have
to do with you know under actuated
systems and balance
and so we wanted to build these high
quality machines still and we thought
that was important for us to continue
learning about really what was the
important parts of the make robots work
um and so there was a little bit of a
philosophical difference there that we
and and so ultimately that's why we're
building robots for the industrial
sector now because the industry
can afford a more expensive machine
because you know their productivity
depends on keeping their Factory going
and so if spot costs you know
um a hundred thousand dollars or more
that's not such a big expense to them
whereas at the consumer level no one's
going to buy a robot like that and I
think we might eventually get to a
consumer level product that will be that
cheap but I think the path to getting
there needs to go through these really
nice machines so we can then learn how
to simplify
so what can you say to the almost the
engineering challenge of bringing down
costs
of a robot so that presumably when you
try to build the robot at scale that
also comes into play when you're trying
to make money on robot even in in the
industrial setting but how interesting
how challenging
of of a thing is that
in particular probably new to an r d
company yeah I'm glad you brought that
last part up the transition from an r d
company to a commercial company
that's the thing you worry about you
know because you've got these Engineers
who love hard problems who want to
figure out how to make robots work and
you don't know if you have Engineers
that want to work on the quality and
reliability and costs that is ultimately
required
um and indeed you know we have brought
on a lot of new people who are inspired
by those problems
but but the big takeaway lesson for me
is
we have good people we have Engineers
who want to solve problems and and the
quality and cost and manufacturability
is just another kind of problem
and because they're so invested in what
we're doing they're interested in and
we'll go work on on those problems as
well and so I think we're managing that
transition very well in fact I'm really
pleased that
I mean uh it's a huge undertaking by the
way right so even having
to get reliability to where it needs to
be we have to have fleets of robots that
we're just operating 24 7 in our offices
to go find those rare failures and
eliminate them it's just a totally
different kind of activity than the
research activity where you get it to
work you know the one robot you have to
work in a repeatable way you know at the
at the high stakes demo it's just very
different
um but I think we're making remarkable
progress against it so one of the cool
things that got a chance to visit Boston
Dynamics and I mean
one of the things that's really cool is
to see a large number of robots moving
about
because I think one of the things you
notice in the research environment is
the MIT for example I don't think anyone
ever has a working robot for prolonged
exactly so like most robots are just
sitting there in a sad state of despair
waiting to be born brought to life for a
brief moment of time but just to have I
just I just remember there's like a
there's a spot robot just I had like a
cowboy hat on it was just walking
randomly for whatever reason I don't
even know but there's a kind of a sense
of sentience to it because it doesn't
seem like anybody was supervising it it
was just doing it I'm gonna stop way
short of the sentience
um it is the case that if you come to
our office you know today and walk
around the hallways
um you're gonna see a dozen robots just
kind of walking around yes all the time
and that's really a reliability test for
us so we have these robots programmed to
do autonomous missions get up off their
charging dock walk around the building
collect data at a few different places
and go sit back down and we want that to
be a very reliable process because
that's what somebody who's running a
brewery a factory that's what they need
the robot to do and so we have to we
have to dog food our own robot we have
to test it in that way
and um so on a weekly basis we have
robots that are accruing something like
um 1500 or maybe 2 000 kilometers of
walking
and uh you know over a thousand hours of
operation every week and that's
something that almost I don't think
anybody else in the world can do because
hey you have to have a fleet of robots
to just accrue that much information
you have to be willing to dedicate it to
that test and uh so that's but that's
essential that's how you get the
reliability that's how you get it what
about some of the cost cutting from the
from the manufacturer side what what
have you learned from the manufacturer's
side of the transition from r d and
we're still we're still learning a lot
there
um we're learning how to cast parts and
solo instead of Mill it all out of you
know Billet aluminum
um we're learning how to get plastic
molded parts for and we're learning
about how to control that process so
that you can build the same robot twice
in a row there's a lot to learn there
and we're only part way through that
process
um we've we've set up a manufacturing
facility in Waltham it's about a mile
from our headquarters and we're doing
final assembly and test of both spots
and stretches you know at that factory
and um
and it's hard because to be honest we're
still iterating on the design of the
robot as we find failures from these
reliability tests we need to go engineer
changes and those changes need to now be
propagated to the manufacturing line and
that's a hard process especially when
you want to move as fast as we do
and that's been challenging and it makes
it you know the folks who are working
supply chain who are trying to get the
cheapest parts for us kind of requires
that you buy a lot of them to make them
cheap and then we go change the design
from underneath them and they're like
what are you doing and so you know
getting everybody on the same page here
that it yep we still need to move fast
but we also need to try to figure out
how to reduce costs that's one of the
challenges of of this migration we're
going through and over the past few
years challenges to the supply chain I
mean I imagine you've been a part of a
bunch of stressful meetings yeah things
got more expensive and harder to get and
yeah so it's it's all been a challenge
is there still room for simplification
oh yeah much more and you know these are
really just the first generation of
these machines we're already thinking
about what the next generation of spots
going to look like
spot was built as a platform so you
could put almost any sensor on it you
know we provided data Communications
mechanical connections uh Power
connections
and but for example in the applications
that we're excited about where you're
you're monitoring these factories for
their health
there's probably a simpler machine that
we could build that's really focused on
that use case and that's the difference
between the general purpose machine or
the platform versus the purpose-built
machine and so even though even in the
factory it would still like the robot to
do lots of different tasks if it's if we
really knew on day one that we're going
to be operating in a factory with these
three sensors in it we would have it all
integrated in a package that would be
easier more less expensive and more
reliable so we're contemplating building
you know a next generation of that
machine